la régie du bâtiment du québec dresse un
portrait accablant des deux fondateurs
des habitations trigone serge rouillard
et patrice st pierre ce sont des faits
des observations qui démontre une
multitude de manquements à la loi sur le
bâtiment
parmi les 17 manquements on note une
structure qui permet aux dirigeants de
trigone d'échapper à la loi de fausses
déclarations
un nombre élevé d'infractions pénales et
municipales soit 329 un service
après-vente déficient selon les
observations et les faits qui sont
mentionnés c'est des éléments qui ont
été répétitif gaston bourgoin on veut
aux dirigeants des habitations trigone
qui lui ont caché qu'il devait payer
pour des infrastructures municipales
alors que c'était un projet clé en main
c'est pour chasser la rbq reproche aussi
aux dirigeants une qualité de travaux
insatisfaisante des vices de
construction des avis de correction non
respectés et une insouciance dans
l'exécution des jugements que des
consommateurs ont obtenu contre eux
[Musique]
autre reproche les dirigeants qui ont
créé une multitude de compagnies
trompent leurs clients qui croient à
tort qu'ils font affaire avec les
habitations trigone le nom habitations
trigone n'apparaît jamais sur leurs
contrats de laisser croire que c'est une
compagnie mais en fait c'en est une
autre
construits c'est l'élément qui
qui est de nature à induire le
consommateur en erreur les habitations
trigone ont refusé de nous accorder une
entrevue dans un courriel les dirigeants
rappellent qu'ils ont droit à une
défense pleine et entière qu'ils feront
valoir devant un régisseur qui lui aura
choisir entre maintenir leur licence les
suspendre ou les annuler ici françois
dallaire et au canada montréal